der rapper haftbefehl ist laut einem
bericht des hessischen rundfunks mit
einer schussverletzung ins klinikum
darmstadt eingeliefert worden
er soll sich selbst die wunden zugefügt
haben offenbar im drogen- und
alkoholrausch bild reporter stefan
schlagenhaufer vor dem krankenhaus ja
was wissen wir denn über den zustand des
rappers den zustand soll ernst sein aber
nicht lebensgefährlich und hier stehe
ich ja gerade vor dem klinikum darmstadt
ist die notfallaufnahme und hier kam
gestern gegen 16 uhr mit seiner
schussverletzung im unterschenkel rein
und ist selbst vorstellig geworden
die polizei die nda befragen wollte er
gegenüber war sehr unkooperativ und im
laufe des tages wurden dann auch noch
seine sich aber die ja auch nur 15
minuten autofahrt entfernt sind vom
klinikum durchsucht und auch seine
wohnung und da fragt man sich natürlich
wo kommt denn die waffe her darf der
haftbefehl eine waffe denn führen das
kann ich leider nicht sagen dass weil
sie nicht und wenn wir jetzt schauen auf
die gemenge lage drogen alkohol plus
eine waffe im spiel
was zieht er auf am horizont für eine
mögliche strafe oder für mögliche
konsequenzen für den nabu
das match ich sie gar nicht klären die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt ja und es
muss auch mal erklärt werden woher die
waffe er hat wo es genau passiert ist es
heißt jetzt im frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel passiert aber soweit
nicht erfahren habe ist es unklar ob es
wirklich dort geschehen ist